the legal teams for two American
teenagers accused of murder in Rome are
stepping up their defense this morning
authorities say Gabriel and Natalia
yourthe and Finnegan elder stabbed and
killed an Italian police officer the
father of Finnegan elder visited his son
in prison for a second day this morning
Seth Doane is outside the prison in Rome
where the teens are being held so Seth
what are their lawyers saying good
morning we have just confirmed with the
lawyers for Natalia that they have filed
a motion to release the teenager from
prison during this period of pretrial
detention now that is a period that
could stretch on for some time the two
teenagers have not yet officially been
indicted and that could stretch on for
up to 18 months before we see an actual
indictment now you may recall the
Natalia earth was the teenager who we
saw that photo of he was blind fold at
the Carabinieri station and we know from
a family's statement that the meeting in
prison earlier this week between him and
his father was difficult and emotional
and it's likely that the defense will
argue it's just too much for the 18 year
old now it is his it is his friend
Finnegan elder who is the one accused of
actually stabbing the plainclothes
Carabinieri officer but in Italy it's
important to note that someone can be
charged with murder even if he or she
did not actually carry out the slang in
Italy the defendant has the right to be
kept in the least restrictive custody
possible that's why there is this
special tribunal set up simply to review
this pretrial detention and a decision
is expected by the middle of the month
now the judge in this case will likely
be weighing a number of things including
the possibility that Natalia Werth could
tamper with evidence or that he could
flee we expect his lawyers to argue for
something along the lines of house
arrest we also know that
Natalia Earth's grandparents live just
outside of Rome we understand from a an
American legal source that this period
can be very difficult for defense teams
here operating in Italy because Anthony
they do not have access to all of the
same legal documents the prosecution
does all right Seth Doane in Rome thank
you Seth